so Native American new religions we
looked in previous Chapters at
traditional Native American religions
and we really just scratched the surface
you know we talked a little bit about
Lakota or or Sue religion we talked a
little bit about um Navajo and and Hopi
religion um I think we touched on a few
other things as well but you know we
didn't get into any great depth and one
of the reasons why we didn't spend an
awful lot of time on these these
traditional Native American religions is
because they haven't had a huge impact
outside of those groups on American
culture in general um you know
Christianity comes in with the European
settlers and to a much lesser extent
Judaism and those are the mainstream
those are the established religions
that's where the the main you know
thrust of culture is is where the power
basis is uh where economic activity is
going on and what you have going on in
American history is a progressive
marginalization of the original
inhabitants the Native
Americans um
now when this sort of thing happens and
this doesn't just happen in in America
what you see occur is some people in
marginalized groups take on the religion
or the culture or pick what whatever
else you like the jobs the lifestyle of
the dominant culture some of them hold
on to traditional ways and tend to be
very conservative about that and then
some tend to try to blend them together
and we talked about this this Prospect
and project of of you know trying to
blend them together when we looked at
missions and we saw that most of the
time it was pretty
unsuccessful um what what might make it
successful is if the people themselves
are not getting it somebody coming com
in from the outside trying to
missionized them but actually trying to
deal with this this essentially
religious problem themselves so there's
this tension that's going to be running
through all of these um to what extent
can
you bring back traditional ways
particularly if those traditional ways
have fallen into disuse if people
haven't been doing them if there's a
break in
continuity um how much can you take on
of the new new European ways and this
extends to beliefs to ideas to culture
in general to practices to Lifestyle to
to economics to um even legal
organization as we're going to see like
for example with the Peyote cult in the
Native American Church um there's this
constant tension of are you are you
accommodating yourself too much or is
this something that you have to do in
order to make things relevant in order
to to continue to survive because if you
try to remain too traditional very often
people say that's no longer relevant to
my
situation I'm not interested in that
particularly if if a group has been
marginalized they can feel that the
traditional ways are no longer uh
effective so your book talks in terms it
uses this Grand term of
revitalization um this is something that
you yourself can relate to um in a in a
sort of personal way how many of you are
kind of burnt out at this time in the
semester I know I am actually I I wish
semesters only lasted 10 weeks as I was
saying before class um what do you do do
you just sort of slog your way through
and and say you know if I just keep my
head down and work work work I'll get
through this or or do you take care of
yourself in some way to try to get
yourself back on track are are you
looking forward to this break that we've
got coming up what are you going to do
are you going to do any first you know
you're probably not going to think about
class related things hopefully you I
know you have to do homework and things
like that but you're going to refresh
yourself in some way and then you can
come back to things somewhat stronger
being able to take interest in it again
when you're burnt out it's hard to take
interest in things this can happen to
you as a student uh not just with a
particular class or a particular
semester but with your
career we call that senioritis you guys
familiar with this this term any of you
have well how many of you are
seniors okay do any of you have senior
rtis yeah yeah I I did when I was a
senior too I couldn't care less about my
classes and that was the first time my
grade started to to fall
um maybe after you're done and you get
out there and you just you know work a
job you'll find that you suddenly have a
renewed interest in things you know the
things that you were studying maybe
right now is not the context for you to
really assimilate all of this maybe some
of it is things you have to to come up
with you know on your own later on so
revitalization Works in personal life
and it can work for an entire culture as
well
um trying to think of examples of this
that that we could easily relate to uh
mean we have a kind of you know
revitalization ritual every four years
really every two years but the four-year
one counts the most what do you what do
you think I'm thinking
of every four years yeah it's not the
Olympics the elections right uh because
you know if you don't like the people in
charge you can throw the bums out bring
in new people they may be just as much
bums as the the last people but you know
at least it seems like there's some sort
of brand shiny new thing going on or if
you like the guys who still there
reelect them you get to actually like
you know take some some role in it um um
so revitalization can work for an entire
culture and it can work in terms of
social things political economic it also
works in terms of
religion and what I've got here is is um
one two three four main things and then
sort of a generic category about what's
going on in the in the present your book
talks about these early uprisings and it
mentions um Pontiac in
1763 uh Tuma in in 1812 what's going on
in in both of these cases there's a war
leader um there's somebody leading an
actual Uprising trying to take that
territory trying to reassert uh the the
rights of of the the nation or the tribe
but there's also a religious leader and
the religious leader is having some sort
of vision some sort of um connection to
the spiritual world that has presenting
an
alternative it's something that you will
use symbolism from the traditional
religion but be adapted to new
circumstances and often times
incorporate symbolism from the the new
civilization that they're they're
encountering and um like your book talks
about Tuma actually tried the the first
pan Indian alliance against the whites
this term pan Indian which I've got down
here with the coost dance that's kind of
important when we see that word pan we
talked about this last time with pan
Orthodoxy it means everybody so for a
long time Native Americans this is part
of what made it so easy for them to be
divided and conquered there wasn't any
sense of you know Native Americans as
one large category of of peoples as
opposed to the whites it was this tribe
this people and very often the first
thing that Native
American peoples would do once once they
got Advanced Weaponry is find another
group that they had some scores with and
settle those scores rather than say
fight the the whites who are encroaching
on their
territories um so what's going on with
this is a sense
of if if they don't band together
they're going to be
submerged uh that things should not just
be a matter of one particular people but
of Native Americans in general like it
says a new sense was a rising from
prolonged contact and conflict with
european-american EUR yeah european-
Americans of the native peoples were
more similar than different in their
character and interest and it was to
their advantage to pursue their common
interests and coordination this is how
uh you know racial identity often comes
on the scene the way in which we this is
sort of an aside the way in which we we
determine race here in the United States
is completely
arbitrary um it's not the same in other
other places it's divided up different
ly you know for instance you know when
we talk about African-Americans what
determines if a person is considered
African-American yeah if they can't
trace theage back to a particular tribe
in Africa no you don't have to go that
far yeah I'm saying they can't go that
far of history of slavery to the way
that culture yeah what I'm saying is
what I'm asking is how do we actually
where do we draw the line who's
African-American who's not and there's
there's actually a rule about
it any African ancestry you're
african-amer it's called the one drop
rule that's not the case in other
countries
um Native
Americans or first peoples in Canadian
Parliament it it depends on on the tribe
sometimes you have to have a certain
percentage uh it varies from from tribe
to tribe Nation to nation and but we
have these census categories you know um
they're they're pretty arbit
and they're based around a sort of
consciousness of belonging to some
particular group you know with respect
to the the the African ancestry although
this will be more relevant in the next
chapter a lot of African-Americans would
go back to Africa and find out that they
weren't considered black they were
considered colored because those are
different
designations in in a lot of African
countries um in any case for Native
Americans there's this growing sense of
you know some sort of racial or cultural
Unity uh in opposition to the the
civilization that they they see
destroying their traditional ways so
your book also talks about um this guy
the shaman smala and smala has a set of
um
Visions in his Visions Indians were the
first humans to be created Mother Earth
rightly belong to its original
inhabitants uh it was being wounded by
all the plows the metal plows that were
tearing up the soil and his movement is
adopted again you see the same thing
religious leader adopted by uh a chief
of the Nez purse who then goes and
starts a um resistance against against
the whites so that takes us through the
early part then we get a more famous
manifestation called The Ghost Dance The
Ghost Dance um starts in Nevada and
California among a particular people and
like the book says the moving spirit in
this case was the the prophet um wwub
who had a vision that was
um sort of a hybridization of
traditional Native American themes and
some things that he's taking from from
the ideology of the whites so he sees a
restoration um in which the Departed
ancestors of the Indians of the day
return to life on on a train the Earth
would open open up swallow up all of
humanity the followers of the ghost ants
would then be resurrected and take over
the property that had been formerly
owned by the now vanished whites and
presumably other Native Americans who
didn't get in on that the ghost Dan
action so what you've got here in the
realm of ideas is kind of a
mixture this notion of of
Resurrection um you know that's that's
traditional Christian imagery the day of
Resurrection
um so you have you know these things
getting fused together uh he starts um
teaching this this Ghost Dance and it
spreads among all the Western peoples
and starts taking a lot of different
forms so different peoples are adapting
it to to their own situations including
the Sue who
um come up with this ghost shirt which
is supposed to make somebody
invulnerable turns out when actually uh
put to the test it doesn't do so so that
that led to some you know um lack of
credence in it now what's interesting
about this is that it's spreading
throughout these inter uh community
links and then it's being adapted by by
uh each Community to to its needs um The
Ghost Dance starts to to fall into
decline because it seems to be
ineffectual um the next one is this this
this Movement by Handsome
Lake and he is um one of the Sena here
we're talking about something you know
in in this local area in New York so the
Sena um like your books that have been
profoundly demoralized by the effects of
Decades of military defeat famine
disease and land speculators alcoholism
witchcraft accusations were Rife and the
Sonica were living in in really
substandard housing so handsome Lake
began to have have an a series of
Visions um in his first Vision he
encounters Three Angels and the angels
call for the Revival of the old Sena
customs and exstension from something so
you've got something almost like a
Holiness code in place similar to when
we talked about um Holiness Christians
so what do you have to do avoid alcohol
abuse witchcraft magic abortion these
are all
practices that were you know becoming
quite prevalent and we're seen as as
bringing about problems uh the next
Vision a fourth Angel appears takes
handsome Lake on a tour of Heaven and
Hell where he can see the the rewards
for the the faithful and the punishments
for the wicked and so you know you've
got all of the the sort of things that
you would find in say traditional
Christianity getting reincorporated into
a traditional
Matrix um
like he says some some other things that
are particularly characteristic of This
was um an ethical code which was
originally apocalyptic so what do we
mean by apocalyptic the end is near you
have to you know fix yourself so that
you're not going to be damned but then
it becomes uh you know sort of here's
how one ought to live here's the right
path um so there like he says there's a
gradual change in emphasis from the
cataclysmic to the ethical the virtues
and Lifestyles it stressed were
basically those of anglo-american
protestant Christianity with a trace of
Quaker influence so Temperance you know
not not drinking alcohol uh being
peaceful being settled social Unity
domestic Harmony prohibitions on
gambling dancing uh all the things that
we're seen to lead to social Decay um
and this this uh ethical code ends up
sort of spreading
likewise throughout sometimes it's it's
spoken of in terms of you know the
traditional virtues you can buy Native
American art where it's got a big circle
with lots of you know feathers coming
off of it each one is a virtue a lot of
that is actually coming from this
conception which is coming from handsome
Lake and his his visions that he's
having
um now when we get to
the piote cult we're looking at
something that's a bit different all of
these have more or less
disappeared the Peyote cult is still
around um it's still practiced under the
aaces of the Native American Church um
the Native American church is not a
church in the sense that we would think
of um you know like the Baptist Church
or the Catholic church or the Orthodox
Church um because the organization
exists primarily to keep the federal
government off their backs um here in
the United States one of the the
peculiarities of our
constitution is that if you organize
yourself as a religion you can do a lot
of things you otherwise ordinarily
couldn't do like what are some examples
that you can think
of sometimes people get very upset about
these like the tax exempt stats for
example um what are some things that you
can do if you organize yourself as a
religion or you tie yourself in with
something sort of religious
body yeah it's heavily protected by
freedom of speech you don't declare
religions Cults like some other
countries do yeah now the term cult like
he points out in the text has a number
of different meanings and here what we
mean is a form of worship um yeah in in
some countries to be designated a cult
is like well the police are going to be
bursting in pretty soon and rounding you
up um you know if you look at for
example uh mainland China the People's
Republic of of China and fall and gong
practitioners um you know they're kind
of strange um but they're they're you
know they're not doing anything super
subversive but they got labeled as a
cult and a lot of them wound up in
re-education camps re-education camps
means concentration camps where you know
you have some extras going on like U
sleep deprivation and being you know
drilled over and over again how you
should think so we don't do that yeah
um we we we have freedom of speech
protected under religious things just
designations what
else what are other sort of exemptions
that you could you could have due to
religion here in this case it's about
drugs peyote is a you know it's a
hallucinogenic
drug um people take it so that they can
experience uh what they what they view
as vision
but the the effects you know we're
talking about something that's within
the same sort of family of effects as
LSD or mushrooms or other
hallucinogens um organizing under the
the framework of the Native American
Church allows them to do that without
getting arrested for taking Controlled
Substances or transporting Controlled
Substances um so that's that's pretty
important that's the main reason to
actually have that now what are they
doing in in um taking so they they just
want to have a good trip you know see a
band maybe taste
colors yeah maybe have some type of
Spiritual Awakening or thinking ways
that they hav't before see or feel
things that they had prior to yeah
that's that's a good list there
um they're I mean they're not the first
people to come up with this idea of of
taking some sort of substance that would
open up the doors of Consciousness as as
I think Huxley called it um and you know
that guy Timothy ly in the 60s he's just
kind of like the latest in a bunch of
people over the centuries who said yeah
maybe if you take something it would
open you up to the possibility of of
spiritual experiences so um the way that
they summarize it here is that it it's
supposed to Pro promote Visions or
hallucinations and and then one is
supposed to contemplate those one's
supposed to sit and think about them the
goal is to to produce a contact of the
individual with the power that permeates
the
cosmos and use of this power to achieve
an altered and more positive perspective
on the problems of everyday life so one
isn't just supposed to be enjoying the
experience as a matter of fact the
experience you know from from people who
have recalled it is not always super fun
uh it can be terrifying uh you can get
very sick
um but the idea is that it's supposed to
allow the person to change themselves to
make themselves into a better person to
to realign themselves with with the
cosmic
forces um now there's there's also an
ethical uh code that goes along with it
the Peyote road and it like like the the
one with with senica it's it's sort of
an
adaptation of other teachings to to this
Native American context stresses similar
virtues such as care of family avoidance
of alcohol
um they had to organize under this this
structure of the Native American Church
in order to avoid to avoid you know
legal prosecution um it's still out
there and it's
uh it's still used quite a bit now let's
talk about this is all before the 60s um
what happens I think back to you know
it's two generations removed for you I
was even born after the 60s I was born
in 1970s so of course I don't remember
the 60s um what do you remember about
the 60s and about some of the cultural
changes that are
happening from your history classes or
your popular culture
stuff what are things that might tie in
with
this yeah was that like free love hippie
all that stuff yeah that was part of it
um and some people would like you know
go out
and take peyote instead of taking LSD
because they they thought they would get
into that you know traditional
practitioners kind of frowned on that
and that's kind of going in the
Direction Where We want to look um in
the 1960s there's this influx of new
ideas into mainstream at least youth
culture and the hippies were were at the
Vanguard of that um a lot of it involved
you know taking drugs being in post of
the war um utopian sort of views on on
Humanity on the family on personal
freedom um most of them were pretty
unsuccessful in the long run they they
were
unsustainable but
um what they did give rise to was was a
sort of change in Consciousness a focus
away from traditional at that time
traditional um mainstream Christian
churches towards alternative you know
viewpoints and so some people started
using Native American uh rituals
Traditions ideas practices as a way to
do that this has led to a lot of
problems a lot of tensions um one of the
documents that I gave you early on in
the semester linked to was the Lakota
declaration of war against exploiters of
Native American spirituality a lot of
Native Americans feel that um what they
call plastic shaman you know people who
aren't
really uh part of the the uh the group
are you know exploiting these these
practices like you know setting up sweat
lodges for example just to do a kind of
generic cleansing thing um and so
there's been a lot of tension with
what's called New Age thought which is
something we're going to look at a
little bit later another thing your book
talks about which is particularly
interesting and this you know we
mentioned this a little bit earlier with
Vatican 2 um Vatican 2 for Catholics
produced a sort of new orientation
towards
um the way in which Christian worship
was carried out you know sort of opened
the doors to doing things a lot of
different ways instead of one single
standard way and also towards
interreligious
dialogue um so you you can see this play
itself out on Native American lands
where for example um um you might have a
a priest who is Native American who is
dressed in traditional Native American
Garb uh saying the Catholic
mass uh or discussions about whether the
the Lakota 7 traditional rights
correspond in some way or another to the
seven sacraments all that sort of
discussion that's what your book likes
to use the term hybridization or
creolization for the earlier term was
syncretizing they don't like to use that
anymore in religious studies but you
know older literature you'll see that
the idea is that people will have sort
of one foot in in two different worlds
and for a lot of Native Americans who
are
religious in part because missions have
been around for so long you will see
this this back and forth thing um one
example not from America but from Canada
would be the nasapi where there are a
traditional hunting Gathering tribe far
up in the north and you'll see them when
they're in Camp they were converted
mostly by by Catholic missionaries so
they'll they'll you know they'll do
things in Camp you know like go to
church once they're out of Camp they
will pray to the animal Masters who are
the ones who run the
hunt uh of course they'll take along
rosaries and scapulars or images of
Saints on the hunt for assistance or
good luck so there's this kind of
blending that that takes place as well
um and you can look at that as being
part of this re
metalization